من جانبه قال وزير الخارجيه الاوكراني
ديميتروكوليبا ان جميع الدول التي وقعت
على اتفاقيه روما الاساسيه ملزمه وفقا
لمذكره المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه باحتجاز
الرئيس الروسي اذا كان داخل اراضيها واضاف
كلب في تصريحات لوسائل اعلام محليه
كمجرم حرب
سيد رجاوي من الان فصاعدا فان جميع الدول
الاعضاء الموقعه على اتفاقيه روما
الاساسيه ملزمه باحتجاز بوت نفسه اذا كان
داخل اراضيها لتنفيذ مذكره المحكمه
الجنائيه الدوليه من وجهه نظر قانونيه
لاسياسيه لاول مره رسميا وقانونيا الرئيس
بوتين متهم كمجرم حرب وليس كاي مجرم وانما
كشخص يسرق الاطفال ويمكن ان تكون سرقه
الاطفال احدى علامات الاباده الجماعيه
قرار المحكمه يعني انه لا يمكن العوده الى
العلاقات مع بوتين